"Кинджали", "Калібри", балістика і дрони.
2 січня Росія випустила по Україні майже 100 ракет різних типів і 35 "шахедів".
Вони атакували критичну інфраструктуру, а також промислові, цивільні та військові об'єкти.
Унаслідок цього постраждало 130 людей, 5-ро загинуло.
Цього разу росіяни трохи змінили тактику обстрілів,
констатує керівник Центру військово-правових досліджень Олександр Мусієнко.
Якщо під час попередньої масованої атаки 29 грудня під ударом була майже вся Україна,
то цього разу основними цілями стали Київ і Харків.
Ворог намагається діяти концентрованіше.
Тобто вони зосереджуються на одній-двох цілях.
У цьому випадку це були два українських міста - Київ і Харків.
І намагаються більшою кількістю засобів повітряного нападу, ракет різних типів:
як крилатих Х-101, Х-555, так і балістичних, аеробалістичних, гіперзвукових "Кинджал",
"Іскандер-М", С-300.
Намагаються пройти наші засоби протиповітряної оборони.
Тобто Росія вирішила бити більшою кількістю ракет
по меншій кількості цілей, бо тоді збивати їх українській ППО значно складніше.
Можливо, ворог надалі якраз буде змінювати підходи,
скажімо, зменшуючи кількість потенційних цілей і географію ударів,
як це буває, що фактично по всіх містах українських, від півночі до півдня, від сходу до заходу.
Зараз вони будуть під час атак концентруватись, вибирати одну-дві цілі.
Для того, щоб більшою кількістю ракет пробувати проходити захист ППО
і таким чином вражати більше цілей.
За п'ять днів, починаючи від 29 грудня,
у комбінованих атаках війська РФ випустили по території України майже 300 ракет і понад 200 "шахедів".
"Ще жодна держава не відбивала подібних ударів", - наголосив президент України Володимир Зеленський.
Це величезне навантаження для протиповітряної оборони України,
каже речник командування Повітряних сил ЗСУ Юрій Ігнат.
Масований обстріл і є на то, що масований, щоб не виснажити,
а навантажити, перевантажити нашу ППО.
Спочатку дрони, потім скільки засобів. І все в одну точку одночасно.
Візьміть Ізраїль. Ізраїль, який був атакований ХАМАСом.
Летіло усе: це і безпілотники ударного типу, балістика летіла,
плюс по балістичній директорії летіли снаряди РСЗВ, "Гради" як одиночні, так і пакетами,
крилаті ракети - там все летіло. І все одночасно.
І ізраїльська ППО, найкраща у світі, мені так видається, не впоралася із відбиттям повністю.
Тому що просто банально не вистачає на таку кількість систем, щоб їх відбити.
От, власне, цей ворог теж має на меті не просто точково завдавати ударів.
Щоб відбитися від таких атак, Україна витрачає багато ракет і боєприпасів, каже Юрій Ігнат.
А ще російські загарбники постійно полюють на українські системи ППО.
Тому військові ЗСУ змушені постійно маскуватися і переміщатися,
щоб їх не виявили і не поцілили ворожі засоби.
Саме тому, що йде велика кількість ракет, дронів, доводиться витрачати велику кількість боєприпасів,
до зенітних гармат і ракет зокрема.
Ми повинні розуміти, що ми постійно витрачаємо ракети,
постійно витрачаємо боєприпаси.
І нам потрібно більше, щоби Росія… вони ж будуть нарощувати відповідно удари,
а нам потрібно нарощувати запаси ракет, щоб їх відбивати.
Військово-промисловий комплекс РФ продовжує виготовляти ракети, незважаючи на санкції.
Росіяни можуть провести ще кілька таких масованих комбінованих атак вже найближчим часом,
не виключають експерти. Для цього вони накопичили чималу кількість засобів.
Я не виключаю, що найближчим часом вони повторять ще одну, дві, три такі атаки
в максимально стислі терміни, наскільки це їм дозволяють їхні умови по перезарядці,
по підготовці і так далі. А потім знову-таки, як мені здається,
скажімо так, десь за цих три місяці, маючи інформацію про розрахункову кількість ракет,
які є у ворога зараз підготовлені, я наголошую: не виготовлені, а підготовлені до запуску,
це в такій кількості, як вони зараз це інтенсивно атакують, може вистачити до п'яти ударів.
І скоріш за все вони будуть намагатися це провести в якомога стисліші терміни.
Сто ракет різних типів на місяць вони можуть виготовляти.
Стосується тих ракет, якими атакували сьогодні, зокрема. І не беремо до уваги ракети С-300, С-400.
Це зенітні ракети. Вони їх просто застосовують по землі.
"Трьохсоток" у них є дуже багато. Але вони можуть ними бити кілометрів 50, 70, до 100 і то…
Але 100 - це вже дуже не точно.
Тому цих ракет "Кинджал" типу Х повітряного базування, "Калібр", "Іскандери" обох типів
- близько ста на місяць, як озвучили в ГУР.
З точки зору затяжної війни, з точки зору економіки,
у Росії все непогано, незважаючи на санкції.
Тож, на жаль для України, російська оборонна промисловість процвітає.
Тому не варто очікувати, що в Росії закінчаться боєприпаси десь найближчим часом.
Експерти не розцінюють такі атаки як помсту Україні за якісь військові здобутки,
на кшталт знищення корабля "Новочеркаськ".
Вони вважають це цілеспрямованим терором проти українського населення.
Ці атаки демонструють, що Росія не відмовляється від тактики терору проти цивільного населення,
від тактики руйнування, "випаленої землі".
Це удар психологічний.
Це фактор психологічного терору проти цивільного населення,
щоб у людей формувалась думка, що тепер так буде завжди.
Ну, ви розумієте, що вони намагаються діяти,
вони намагаються посилити таку паніку, розпач,
і плюс спричинити руйнування, особливо у критичній інфраструктурі.
Взагалі формулювання помста і так далі - це використовується російською пропагандою
виключно для внутрішньої аудиторії.
У них є свої стратегічні задуми відповідні.
Вони накопичували ракети не просто так, щоб здачі давати.
Вони накопичували вдарити і робити те, про що я щойно казав,
- завдавати ударів в інформаційному і військовому плані для того, щоб пригнітити Україну, змусити здатися і так далі.
Відповідно представлено це буде, все зрозуміло, своїм глядачам,
як акт "возмездія", помсти за корабель.
Вони це роблять щодня, навіть не завдаючи таких ударів.
Вони беруть, просто "збивають" у себе у "Фейсбуках" чи в себе в інформаційних ресурсах по 5 літаків наших на день,
"Хаймарсів" пачками.
Надані союзниками системи Patriot, NASAMS та Iris-T продовжують рятувати сотні життів.
Система Patriot збиває не лише балістичні цілі, а й аеродинамічні цілі.
Але саме захист від балістики забезпечує, що доказано цієї ночі зокрема.
10 "Кинджалів" було знищено, які летіли в серце столиці, скажімо так, які мали якісь потенційні цілі там.
Так, звичайно, є руйнування, є від уламків і від незбитих ракет на Київщині.
Але подивіться, скільки засобів повітряного нападу було направлено - 99!
І це лише ракет. Ще 35 дронів.
Це величезна кількість. На це все треба ракети і засоби.
Засоби і ракети, які ми отримуємо від Заходу.
Росія й надалі тероризуватиме мирних українців,
щоб поширити панічні настрої в суспільстві.
Україна потребує більше систем ППО і снарядів до них, щоб дати відсіч РФ.
Для цього необхідна швидка реакція Заходу.
Це може підштовхнути Європейський Союз і Сполучені Штати,
щоб розблокувати пакети.
Проблема тут у тому, що пакет, який зараз розглядає Євросоюз, набагато менший, ніж спочатку було погоджено.
У США кажуть, що це останній пакет для України.
Тож навіть якщо Україна отримає цю допомогу, питання в тому,
чи буде вона продовжувати отримувати допомогу після цього?
І на скільки цієї допомоги вистачить Україні?
Україні також знадобляться боєприпаси. Україні знадобиться більше зброї.
Схоже, Великобританія вирішила відправити в Україну ракети ППО.
Але це не все, що потрібно Україні. І питання в тому, чи може Захід надавати саме те,
що потрібно Україні, щоб протриматися довше за Росію?
Ми відбиваємося. Бачите, як це відбувається.
Але Захід, зокрема, повинен зрозуміти, що перестати допомагати Україні
- це перестати допомагати собі.
Україна, захистивши Європу, будучи таким собі буфером, стіною,
створивши ешелоновану ППО, зробить надійну систему протиповітряної оборони,
захистить Захід від небажаних наслідків і так далі.
Тому не допомагати Україні - це вистрелити собі в ногу сьогодні.
Це мають зрозуміти і в Сполучених Штатах, і країни Європи, які сумніваються.